so you're Exxon Mobil in 2007 and you've
run into a big problem your biggest
Money Maker was getting oil from
Venezuela for years you had enjoyed
unlimited access to the world's largest
known oil reserves but now Venezuela
just kicked you out that's right
Venezuela's president had just
nationalized all its private oil fields
which meant that foreign oil companies
like Exxon Mobil were banned you had
just lost your biggest money maker and
you had to find an alternative fast
luckily another country caught your eye
Venezuela's neighbor a country called
Guyana Guyana is a very poor country in
South America that is right for oil
exploration after all it is next door
neighbors with the biggest oil reserves
in the world so there's gotta be oil in
Guyana right the problem is even though
many have tried no one has ever been
able to find oil in Guyana but you knew
you had to at least give it one more
shot and it would take you eight
terrible years after Venezuela kicked
you out until you finally did the
impossible you discovered oil in Guyana
and in the last decade some 11 billion
barrels of oil has been found which is
the most significant discovery of its
kind in recent years guyana's newest oil
Discovery by Exxon Mobil at katabak
within the starboard block has increased
the discovered recoverable resource to
approximately 10 billion oil equivalent
borrows ding ding ding it was a miracle
and it turned out to be one of the
biggest oil discoveries ever you had hit
the jackpot and suddenly you were back
in business but just because you
discovered oil in Guyana doesn't mean
it's yours no it still technically
belongs to the guy in these people which
means you have to somehow convince this
Sovereign Nation to give up the one
thing that will lift them out of poverty
but how on Earth do you do that well the
great news is that as a poor country the
people are easily fooled the politicians
are very affordable to bribe at the time
guyana's GDP was a measly 4 billion
dollars while Exxon Noble you made 4
billion dollars every six days
that kind of money you can do anything
all you gotta do is use someone that
cash to fool the guy in these people
into welcoming you with open arms and
once you get your foot in the door you
can start systematically taking over
every aspect of Guyanese Society you'll
be able to silently take over their
governments to take over their Free
Press their legal system and ever since
the discovery of oil in Guyana that's
exactly what Exxon Mobil has been doing
today Exxon Mobil has completely and
utterly colonized Guyana without a
single shot ever being fired and no one
has been the wiser one journalist wrote
the best in Guyana it's become hard to
distinguish where the oil company ends
and where the government begins
this is a story about how one
transnational Corporation managed to
take over an entire nation-state in the
span of just a few years stay dangerous
and let's get into it
foreign
[Music]
there is a reason why Exxon is a very
successful company on the stock markets
they are willing to do anything to make
their shareholders happy and you can bet
that they're pouring all that extra
money they're making into the best Wall
Street analysts to help them make even
more money with their money Wall Street
analysts have been traditionally
reserved only for the ultra wealthy but
one company is trying to change that
Seeking Alpha today sponsor seeking
Alpha's goal is to give you the same
Edge you would have if you had your own
Wall Street analyst by your side and
they've already got over 250 000 Plus
members taking advantage of this from
the past 19 years Seeking Alpha has been
the go-to place for independent and
balanced stock research fundamental
analysis tools crowdsource debate
reliable news and actionable Market data
their stock coverage gives you both the
Bull and Bear case for each stock so
that you can weigh in and make an
informed decision their news lets you
understand why the market and the stocks
in your portfolio are moving or why
they're about to move their data allows
you to have professional caliber tools
right at your fingertips and with their
premium subscription you can get
unlimited access to all of this and the
best part is that you can try Seeking
Alpha premium for free for 14 days by
clicking the link below click the link
below to get a 14 day trial of Seeking
Alpha premium now I am not able to start
financial advisor and thanks to Seeking
Alpha for being the paid sponsor of this
video
here's what you have to understand about
taking over a country whether it be by
force or more economic means it's that
if the people hate you eventually
they're gonna revolts just like what
happened to you in Venezuela we want to
prevent that from repeating itself here
so the first step in colonizing a poor
country like Ayana is to win the hearts
and minds of the public it's very simple
if the public loves their occupiers they
won't vote so from the moment that you
and National oil Discovery you told
everyone that this oil was gonna make
them Rich that oil money was going to
create all these new jobs that all the
money would trickle down and that it was
going to put guyana's economy on the map
that it would Oregon 150 billion dollars
over the next 30 Years but you made sure
to tell the public unimportant caveats
let's face it you poor people don't have
the knowledge and equipment to dig all
this oil out of the ground and refine it
so why don't you let us as Exxon Mobil
mind the oil for you and we'll all share
in the riches and being that you told us
to a population where 40 of the people
live on less than six dollars a day what
do you think they said to your little
proposition they said yes obviously this
is everything they ever dreamed of quote
people were going crazy talking about
oil wealth End quotes and it wasn't just
the people Exile was pushing this idea
and so was the government End quotes the
oil gods have finally smiled down on
Guyana and sent Exxon Mobil to change
everything from the bet it was the
perfect narrative and to further your
influence your first big investment in
the country was to sponsor guyana's
National cricket team and Guyana Cricket
is the equivalent of football in the U.S
so this was a big deal it made it look
like you cared you even pay for cricket
matches to be shown on TV and make sure
that every Guyanese player was wearing
the Exxon Mobil logo on their shirt for
everyone to see sponsoring cricket and
Guyana was like if Exxon Mobil created
the Super Bowl in America sure it would
cost you a few million dollars but the
payoff in public opinion was priceless
and your plan worked perfectly well when
you've walked in the streets you could
hear every Guyanese saying thank God for
Exxon End quotes now that's some
effective PR you as an oil giant were a
hero in the eyes of the public their
knight in shining armor that had come to
save them out of poverty now all you
needed was for the government to love
you as well
[Music]
thank you
just like many poor countries Guyana is
very corrupt in fact it's one of the
most corrupt countries in the entire
region and you know what that means
right that means Guyana is very
affordable to bribe so you got to work
turning the Guyanese government into
your well-paid puppets you whine you
done you schmooze your way into the
highest Circles of the Guyanese
governments and before you knew it your
oil Executives were watching cricket
games with the Guyanese presidents while
the guy needs vice president regularly
held press conferences talking up Exxon
Mobil and defending it against the
country's Regulators it was the perfect
setup with the right context and just a
little bit of money buying favors from
the government became as easy as buying
vegetables from a supermarket and thanks
to your little deal with the Guyanese
government no outside supervisors were
allowed onboard exxon's oil rigs and
production vessels even your mining
permits and documents were locked away
from the people who were supposed to
regulate your money in the first place
you didn't just have the support of the
government to mine oil you also had a
support to do about just whatever you
wanted in America although you can buy
politicians there is no way you're going
to be able to buy off the entire
governments heck I don't even think
BlackRock has been able to buy off the
entire U.S governments but in a small
poor country like Guyana Exxon was
probably able to do this with just a
couple hundred million dollars and he
didn't waste a second taking full
advantage of it
[Music]
foreign
think about it the public only cares
about issues when the mainstream media
is blasting it in their faces 24 7.
coronavirus coronavirus covid-19 and the
same is doubly true for a small
uneducated country like Guyana if pesky
independent journalists are blasting
your name into bad lights the public
will turn on you which meant that
guyana's Free Press was next on The
Chopping Block you needed to get rid of
all those goody two-shoe journalists
before they start exposing you the
public can't get mad over what they
don't know so you turn to your Palace in
the government again this time you would
give them money and in exchange they
would go to all the independent Guyanese
journalists working on oil and
environmental stories and hired them to
Warfare state run news instead they
would offer these journalists a car a
raise a fancy title just for joining the
government's official Newsroom and it
worked in a country where the average
annual salary was just 6 500 a year in
2019 no one could resist the offer one
by one journalists were bought off and
since they now all work for the
governments you had the last say on
every story they published the results
no more negative stories about you or
oil in the news without anyone to report
on your shitty deals the public had no
way of knowing what you were really up
to so now you don't need all of Guyana
to love you anymore you just need to
keep them in the dark but even with the
media in your pocket there's still going
to be some stragglers that learn about
your dark Deeds what if they try to sue
you or use the legal system against you
well then I guess we're just gonna have
to take over the legal system next
the only way for regular people to take
on a company of your size would be for
them to hire really good lawyers so what
do you do you take your billions of
dollars in oil money and start paying
off as many law firms in the country as
possible put every single lawyer out
there on a retainer that way no matter
which law firm people go to they'll
always get the same answer sorry we
can't represent you because we have a
conflict of interests no lawyers no case
no case no fines of Regulation simple
right and guess what lawyers and Guyana
make a typical salary of just seventeen
thousand dollars U.S a year which means
all you need is a few thousand dollars
to throw at each of them and boom the
legal system is yours and if people go
to the environmental agencies that are
supposed to be completely independent
and objective well boy did you have a
surprise for love because guess what
you're funning them too all you had to
do was throw money at the poor
underfunded environmental agencies that
way everyone thought you were the good
guy trying to protect the environments
while also stopping them from going
after you in the process No One's Gonna
bite the hand that feeds it
[Music]
as Exxon Mobil your drilling operation
in Guyana is one of the most dangerous
in the industry like Deepwater Horizon
level dangerous the Deepwater Horizon
explosion spilled oil and gas throughout
the entire Gulf of Mexico and it cost BP
69 billion dollars to clean it up for
comparison guyana's current GDP is just
8 billion dollars so if a spill happened
even if Gaia used all of its GDP which
is Impossible by the way it would take
them more than eight years to clean up
that kind of spill but luckily if a
spill did happen they wouldn't have to
do that rights see in most cases oil
companies running this sort of money
operation not only have insurance in
case of an accident but they also have
to guarantee that they're going to pay
for all the cleanup costs if it exceeds
their insurance and it makes sense
you're planning on making hundreds of
billions of dollars off of this
country's oil so the least you can do is
pay if something goes wrong right well
not in the case of Exxon Mobil in Guyana
see once you had infiltrated the
Guyanese governments and got them to
hand over all the money rights to you
you thought that well if we could get
them to do this why not take it a step
further why not mix so we don't have to
make any guarantees that will clean up
after any accidents that happen that's
right if any sort of oil accidents
happen Exxon Mobil is legally off the
hook now to be clear you still get on
your word that you would clean up any
mess you made but there's nothing in the
fine print saying that you have to so
now if a spill did happen it would be
the guy needs taxpayers who are on the
hook to pay for it and obviously this
did not sit well with a lot of people
with this move you have finally revealed
your true colors that you didn't really
care about the people or the country it
showed that you were just in it for the
money all along and so suddenly public
opinion about Exxon mobils started to
change and the people took you and the
Guyanese government to courts accusing
you of working with the government to
break the whirls but luckily the
Guyanese government refused to stop
supporting you this was the first time
in history that an oil company and a
government environmental agency was on
the same side of a lawsuit and even when
guyana's High Court ruled against you
the government just wouldn't accept it
instead they lost an appeal on your
behalf yes the government was fighting
for Exxon Mobil and with that kind of
power now all you had to do was sit back
and let the money any fluid
[Music]
congratulations with the government
lawyers and even the environmental
agencies on your side you had finally
completed your takeover now you can sit
back and make your billions while making
sure that none of it actually goes back
to the Guyanese people but look you say
guyana's GDP has been going to the moon
since we started mining you say the guy
needs people should be thankful for you
but how much of that money has actually
gone back into the country turns out not
so much guyana's government was so
desperate to keep you and your money in
the country the deal they sent allows
you to deduct up to 75 of your Revenue
as expenses before the rest is split
between you and the governments it
doesn't matter if your profit margin
really is 25 or not that was the deal
the government signed and even if they
wanted to find out what your real profit
margin was they don't have the money or
manpower to audit you so you can just
keep breaking in billions while Guyana
stays as poor and underdeveloped as ever
ensure more and more people are starting
to realize how you calm them out of
their oil but with more and more oil
being discovered every year and more oil
was being dubbed by ExxonMobil given How
Deeply rooted Exxon Mobil is with
government and the economy it may just
be too late
[Music]
thank you